You'll never find me in bed at midday.
What I know now that I didn't know ten
years ago...that getting your eyebrows
done by a professional is life-changing.
When I grow old you'll find me growing
flowers in my garden.
When I'm in a bad mood I listen to 'The
Greatest Showman Soundtrack' or the
'Now And Then' soundtrack, both are amazing.
The harder the day, the deeper and the
hotter and the bubblier my bath.
When I want to be a badass I will wear a
blazer and heels.
On my wedding day you'll find me
laughing and smiling with all my nearest
and dearest.
My guilty pleasure is a McDonald's
breakfast with extra hashbrowns.
The beauty product I can't live without
is concealer because I was not gifted
with bright under eyes.
The thing is that no one ever told me
about being a YouTube star is how many
cool opportunities would ever come from
turning on a camera and making some
videos about things I was interested in.
Clarins bronzer
because I absolutely love those. The
Zoella Beauty Shower Shake because it's
a good double product for being clean
and feeling moisturized so I would
probably take that and I would also take
my Smith and Colt Lash Dance mascara. If
you loved this video don't forget to
subscribe!